[Music]
[Applause]
lisa vanderpump being godmother i mean
that's pretty incredible i love that so
much i have to show you a picture i've
not shown anyone this one yet but it's
so huge hold up hold up where is it oh
i'm excited look at this
this was their first easter okay that
needs to go on the gram asap
why was lisa kind of the perfect person
to
give this role to well she took the role
um you know she was she basically made
herself godmother which is perfectly
fine with me because she really is the
best fairy godmother i'm truly
truly bloody honoured the lgbt community
is so dear to her heart so to have my
family be a part of hers it really is
just an amazing thing she has quickly
become one of america's sweethearts but
unlike so many others in her position
she has used her platform to actively
support and raise our community the lgbt
community
and while lance is now living his best
life with husband michael and their
twins violet and alexander he admits
coming out during his boyband days would
have been detrimental to his career
do you actually think it would have hurt
sales at that time and that hurt the
world tours and all those things
unfortunately i think yes nsync would
have uh
you know been tarnished if i would have
come out but i would have loved to see
what that would have done
at that time in the late 90s of coming
out in such a big group
would it have helped many people i hope
so would it have destroyed our career
probably
[Music]
what are your hopes for these beautiful
babies you have as they grow older i
hope for kindness you know i hope they
go out in this world and create
positivity and kindness
and you know just help change this world